so wait Nick it took me I don't know how
many minutes my producer can tell me
it's a mean not long to have a friends
reference so I'm just saying it was such
a huge you know pop-culture impact on
all of us so how many minutes into a
meeting you know into meeting David did
you actually ask a friend's question or
mention friends at all like an idiot you
did the biggest shows ever on TV in life
I am Dora I mean the thing was I said I
did have to I mean you know David and I
mates now but I guess in the first
instance I obviously had to hold my
tongue a hell of a lot because you know
I grew up watching is one of my favorite
things ever but I remember actually I
think I think David do you mention it
first because I remember we were doing
an improv thing with Julia this was with
Julia Davis which was for a show that
never happened but they would come over
and we're doing some improv stuff
together and I remember in doing
character said you left your phone with
us and Ewan character said I know when
you check in my phone I've got Jennifer
Aniston's number on that phone and it
was and you said it in character and
literally me and Julia almost fell off
our seats
I didn't think we've really spoke about
it maybe there was one time when I was
gonna do I was possibly considering
doing a play there was one story that we
had a meeting recently or this year I
think on breaking stories for the second
season hopefully gonna shoot this this
fall we'll see and and and it was
talking about pitching a story in which
my character got yeah dude we can't we
can't do that this is the thing this is
the problem you know it's such a
successful show well how many to 236 and
I and I hope by now you've seen them all
neck
but I am but this is a thing it's such
an iconic show that you have to when
you're writing trying to like break
story and do B plus and so on you
suddenly realize that friends have done
pretty much everything so but I would be
even if there was a marketing idea and I
don't think I remember pitching into not
so much like drinking the you know stuff
out the straws they're kind of like on
in forensics I remember pitching a
marketing idea to you and I think you
said I we did it in France subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going